a proof of work protocol is a vehicle
really by which somebody can effectively
prove to you they've engaged in a
significant amount of computational
effort
uh now proof of work protocols often
amount to puzzles and these puzzles that
can on the one hand be challenging to
solve
and by that i mean they require some
some serious computational effort and
really can't be short-circuited
but on the other hand
that effort can actually be
easily verified and it can be verified
in far less time than it took to conduct
that effort in the first place
okay and there are a number of
applications of such protocols so for
example if you've heard of the bitcoin
the bitcoin electronic payment system
that system actually leverages
a proof of work scheme within the
context of
creating what are known as
transaction blockchains okay
now aside from bitcoin which is a very
recent uh
user of these types of of proof-of-work
schemes uh these schemes have been
proposed in the past for other
applications for example uh
proof-of-work teams have been proposed
for doing things like deterring denial
of service attacks or dos attacks and
here the idea is that the requester
let's say a particular service would
have to solve a
a very specific computational problem a
proof-of-work puzzle
before being allowed to use a service
and the idea here is that the the
computational effort exerted is
effectively a way to throttle the
requester okay the responder can in turn
easily check that the requester carried
out the requisite work and only if that
work was carried out while the responder
respond to that request for service
okay
now the original application for
these types of proof-of-work protocols
the first place that i've seen it
proposed is in the context of being able
to deter spam email and then obviously
we all know what spam email is hopefully
these are messages that you don't want
in your inbox that maybe come to you in
an unsolicited fashion and the idea here
is that a proof of work protocol can be
it turns out it can be tied to a
particular email message
and this is conceptually like let's say
fixing a posted stamp to a message
but rather than paying that stamp or
paying for that stamp using money you're
basically paying for that stamp via cpu
cycles so for a legitimate sender who is
only sending out a small number of
messages this type of proof-of-work
protocol will not amount to very much
it's going to be a minor deterrent since
it's only executed a very small number
of times
it's kind of an impediment but it's not
something that's so unreasonable
okay now for a spammer who might be
sending out a lot of messages maybe
hundreds of thousands or millions of
messages
it might be prohibitively expensive to
repeatedly expand so many cpu cycles
for each message in each sender to whom
that message is being sent
okay so hopefully this gives you a
flavor for some of the the applications
of these proof-of-work protocols let me
actually dive into how they they work in
practice okay
so first of all the way that i like to
think of these protocols is that
typically they work relative to a given
challenge string and we're going to call
this this challenge string and we'll
label it with the with the letter c so c
is going to be kind of a challenge
string
and what the
person trying to engage in the protocol
will do the approver of the work
will basically
try to come up with a corresponding
proof
that is tied to this challenge string
it's going to be kind of response
associated with this challenge that has
a very specific mathematical property in
relation to this challenge okay and as
you point out maybe that when i when i
talk about a challenge string here for
example in the context of spam this
challenge string might actually
represent an email message okay so it's
going to be something very specific to
the task at hand
okay now what the
prover will do is come up with the
response string and let's call the
response string
we'll call the response string r
actually let's use the term p4 since
maybe we can we can think of it as a
proof
okay approve for response
okay and the idea is that the
prover will come up with this proof or
response string and he has to come up
with a string such that when you
concatenate the challenge in the
response and you
you take the two together and you
apply a cryptographic hash function so
let's say come with a cryptographic hash
function like shot 256 or
uh anything of that nature if i take the
challenge string and the proof string
and concatenate together and apply the
cryptographic hash function apply these
mathematical transformations that
represent the cryptographic hash
function
i want to come up with a proof string
such that the output
under this hash function will have a
very specific property that property the
prefix of the the output
the first
large number of bits will all be zero so
let's say the first
uh 40 bits or
first 30 bits or some number of bits
will be zero okay
and then the other bits can be whatever
whatever they would normally be
okay so obviously what you're trying to
do here is come up with a a proof string
that has a relationship with a challenge
string and that relationship happens to
be one that happens or that is taken
with respect to a particular hash
function and really
incorporates or considers what the
output of the hash function will be
when the proof string is concatenated
with the challenge string okay now if
you let's say have a good cryptographic
hash function then the only known way to
find this type of approved strings to
effectively uh try
a lot of different possibilities
effectively doing brute force by trying
a lot of different proof strings until
you find one that works
now if you let's say needed to find an
output that contained about
40 consecutive zeros in it that would
require you to perform about
2 to the power 40 steps okay 2 to the
power 40
different hash function invocations you
have to try 2 to the 40 different
strings
and one of them would would likely work
if you tried uh 2 to the 40 such strings
that actually requires you to try about
2 to the 40 just to give you a sense is
approximately uh one trillion so if you
tried a trillion different strings out
and you hash them each
you would likely come up with one string
that had the first 40 bits being zero
now sometimes it might take you a lot
less than a trillion steps sometimes it
might take you a little bit more okay
you might get very lucky you might get
very unlucky
but on average it will take you about
one trillion steps to find
a string where the first 40 bits are
equal to zero okay
so this is something that's that's not
uh easy but it's also not outside the
realm of possibility
now to understand why it's really hard
to solve these types of proof-of-work
schemes and
more efficiently than maybe simply doing
brute force i think it's helpful to
recall that the output of a
cryptographic hash function
looks more or less random in fact each
output bit
looks like a series of of coin flips
okay so it's kind of like it's like
flipping a coin and if it comes up heads
you would have a zero and if it comes up
tails you can think of it as a one and
so what you're really doing is saying
if i flipped 40 coins what are the odds
that you would have 40 consecutive heads
on those 40 coin flips now obviously
that
likelihood is very small
but it's not outside the realm of
possibility if you took 40 coins
and you flipped those 40 coins about a
trillion times
you would actually expect to see one
instance in which
all 40 coins came up as heads
okay out of a trillion tries
okay now one interesting thing with
these proof-of-work schemes is they can
be ratcheted up or ratcheted down so for
example let's say you you want to
require even more computational heavy
lifting to come up with a correct proof
string okay let's say you want to
increase the
the
the work that's going to be proved here
what you can effectively do in that case
is you can just increase the requirement
on the number of leading zeros so every
time you add an additional zero you
effectively double
the computational horsepower needed on
average okay and that's because you're
effectively requiring
one more coin flip to come up heads and
that entails doubling the number of coin
flips okay so if i had 41 coin flips and
i required 41 straight heads that would
require about twice as much effort as
just requiring 40 straight heads
okay and likewise every time you remove
a zero from consideration or from the
requirement that would reduce the
computational horsepower needed to about
half of what it was previously so for
example if i only require the first 39
bits to be zero that will require about
half as many coin flips as requiring the
first 40 bits to be zero okay now the
neat thing is that once you come up with
the solution let's say that
somebody tries you know a trillion times
they finally come up with
a proof string that works it's very easy
to validate that this proof string in
fact is a correct proof of work all you
have to do is you take the challenge and
you take the the proof string and you
hash them together so for example just
if somebody proposes this this one
string uh let's call it p prime all you
do is you take the challenge
and you take p prime and you input them
into a hash function
okay and you see if the first 40 bits
are all zero so all this requires you to
do is apply a hash function once
to the concatenation of c and p prime
and you can verify that the output
indeed has the requisite number of zeros
in front of it and
if you see that the output has the
requisite number of zeros
then you can consider the proof of work
valid because you know it must have
taken somebody a lot of time
a lot of tries really to provide or come
up with the string p prime
such that the concatenation of c and p
prime
gives you a number of zeros
under the application of this
cryptographic hash function so as you
can see these these schemes are quite
simple
but quite clever at the same time they
really amount to coming up with a proof
string that has a very specific
mathematical relationship with the
original challenge strings hopefully
this video gave you a flavor for for the
mechanics of how these proof-of-work
protocols
work